the ons estimates that one in 90 people
in england
had coveted 19 last week 618 thousand
and 700 people are estimated to have had
covid in
england that is up from 568
100 the week earlier uh well let's get
more analysis of all that from our
science correspondent thomas more
thomas yes the office of national
statistics survey that comes out every
friday is the most reliable survey of
the week because it
is random it looks at people whether or
not they have symptoms
and that is distinct from the daily
figures we get which causes just those
who have symptoms and they do show
another rise in the number of people who
were infected last
week this is up to uh the weekend uh a
rise of
fifty thousand uh to six thousand six
hundred and eighteen
thousand uh people uh one in ninety as
you say
uh but and this is a big but uh the the
rate of infection does seem to be
slowing so
uh there were an estimated 45 700 people
a day being infected last week
that's down 12 from almost 52
000 a day the week before now one week's
figures do not make a trend so we
shouldn't read too much
into that but of course large parts of
the country have been living under
restrictions
for some time and indeed the northeast
and the north west
cases do seem to be leving or leveling
off and in the northwest perhaps
declining
but we would want to see that continuing
uh for another couple weeks yet before
we'd be certain that
uh things were on the turn so uh in the
northwest still
one in 45 people infected that that is
markedly higher than
the south east outside london where it's
just one in 217.
so potentially some good news there adam
but i still think it's early days and
certainly the the government scientists
will
be wanting to see some longer trend data
before they say that that what they've
done has actually worked